a slice of the beaten family history for
22 years it was an awful decision to
make absolutely awful decision to make
now their farm shop will close with a 76
000 pound energy bill impossible to pay
i thought somebody made a mistake
so i queried it um and then
it came back now that that was right and
obviously over that couple of days the
price had
changed again
devastated i think devastated is the
correct word to use really for that
like schools and charities businesses
don't benefit from the energy price cap
they're struggling with a cut in
footfall too here in reading and the uk
consumer confidence is also at a record
low
i'm a single parent mum part-time work
charlotte's already turning to buy now
pay later loans even for her daughter's
fourth birthday
changed a lot of shopping
things yeah i'm quite fortunate to have
a good family but cutting back a lot on
the food shop as well changing a lot of
going around a lot more to like algae
lidl on a shop instead of just one big
shot so using it but then that uses the
fuel which is a massive high rise
latest figures show a slight upturn in
july for retail sales but that was
driven by online promotions you can see
overall on this graph the line is
declining
there's no doubt the economy is on a
long term downward trajectory but july's
retail figures were better than
forecasters expected a small sign
perhaps that the economy is holding up
meaning the bank of england may be
inclined to raise interest rates next
month as it tackles inflation
we're a football club we're a music
venue we're a stand-up comedy venue
we're a boxing club but the hospitality
sector wants urgent action mark runs a
music venue calling for an energy price
cap for businesses
it's going to be an absolute wasteland
out there shutters will be going down
right across this land
and it won't be long before we have to
do that
it would once we get to winter time i i
tried to think what the situation is
going to be
consumers and businesses with a crisis
of confidence reflecting a darkening
mood across the uk economy adele
robinson sky news